ليس سهلا ان يجد احد اكثر شعوب العالم
استهلاكا للخبز نفسه بلا خبز واقع يتعامل
معه التونسيون اليوم مجبرين في ظل اضراب
المخابز المستفيده من الدعم اضراب لم يترك
للمواطنين بديلا من التزود بالخبز غير
المدعم وسط بحيره ومخاوف من ان يطول امد
الازمه
في المقابل يبدو ان اصحاب المخابز
المدربين قد حسنوا امرهم لا رجوع الى
العمل قبل ان تلبي الحكومه مطلبهم
الرئيسيه بسداد مستحقاتهم منحه الدعم
البالغه نحو 80 مليون دولار
الاذان صغير واللي من الجمش يحل مشاكل
قطاع المخابز يمسح اب للمره الثانيه يا
خلاله اقل من شهرين يجد التونسيون انفسهم
امام شبحي غياب الخبز ليراكمه ذلك ازمه
فقدان بعض المواد الاساسيه وارتفاع اسعار
بعضها الاخر في ظل تدهور القدره الشرائيه
للمواطنين
يتعايش التونسيون منذ اشهر مع نقص غير
مسبوق لعشرات المواد الاستهلاكيه في
الاسواق الخبز والحليب والدواء مواد بات
وجودها مهددا في ظل ما تشهده البلاد من
اضطرابات انقطاعيه وصعوبات ماليه عطلت
عجله الانتاج قبل سنوات مباشره
انت عارف روحك مثلا
يجوز
سعيد خلال زيارته لاحد اكبر مصانع الحليب
اختزل اسباب فقدان المواد الاستهلاكيه في
جانب واحد وهو الاحتكار
والاحتك
وبالفعل اخر تنبيه
والصعبه وتزايد وتيره المطالب القطاعيه
تحبس الحكومه التونسيه انفاسها قبل
اسبوعين من موعد اجتماعها الاخيره مع
صندوق النقد الدولي لضمان الحصول على
التمويل
مليار دولار وفي ظل الارتفاع نسبه التضخم
لتبلغ 9.8
مساءا فاطمه الجزيره تونس